here at whirlpool were the largest
manufacturer of appliances in the world
whirlpool has been around almost 104
years it started right here in Benton
Harbor Michigan we have a hundred
thousand employees now worldwide we're a
very relationship based company we kind
of have small-town values the center of
everything is the customer because
that's where our responsibility lies
coming to work at whirlpool you get to
work with some really great people and
you get to be a part of products that
are exciting be able to execute our
business well requires collaboration
between sales and merchandising teams
between our manufacturing our product
teams the need that we have to be
connected the speed with which we need
to operate have gone up the opportunity
to make a global company feel local
entrepreneurial feel fast-paced that's a
big challenge Google Apps helps us get
there what we've really done is create
an opportunity for people to collaborate
truly on a global basis regardless of
location time in place and that makes a
huge difference in terms of the speed at
which we can operate
we're tracking our metrics all in one
place for the entire team we're looking
at it and saying how we're going to be
able to deliver our products when our
customers need it the tools really do
create that kind of empowerment the
third people lose to be creative and be
their best selves for work we're really
creating products that can make families
lives a little bit better in a
behind-the-scenes kind of way when we
think about our customer we try to think
about the way that they would want to
spend their lives and how we can make
that better